In 2017, Amazon announced that its Prime streaming
video service would soon be home to a truly
epic project: A TV series based on J.R.R.
Tolkien's massive Lord of the Rings legendarium.
While Lord of the Rings itself has already
been adapted for live action, quite successfully
in the form of Peter Jackson's Oscar-winning
film trilogy, this series will be set many
years before those events.
We now know that Amazon's Lord of the Rings
prequel series will take viewers to the Second
Age, a period of time that ended nearly 3,000
years before Frodo Baggins was born and culminated
in the War of the Last Alliance, which saw
Isildur cut the One Ring from Sauron's hand
in battle.
The Second Age itself is also vast, covering
a little more than 3,400 years of history
that included wars, the rising and falling
of kingdoms, and of course the creation of
the Rings of Power, including the One Ring
to Rule Them All.
There's a vast canvas for Amazon to work with,
and that means a lot of different characters
from Tolkien lore could pop up.
Here are our picks for who we'd most like
to see, with a particular emphasis on characters
who haven't already starred in a big-budget
movie.
Elendil is a character who appears for only
a moment in the prologue to the Lord of the
Rings films, as the High King of Gondor and
Arnor who helped forge the Last Alliance that
was able to defeat Sauron at the end of the
Second Age.
That's enough to make him a legend, but the
story of how Elendil got to that point is
what makes him one of the most compelling
characters in the Second Age.
Elendil lived in the legendary kingdom of
Numenor at a time when its last king was corrupted
by Sauron.
Even as the king led Numenor and its people
astray, Elendil remained faithful, and when
the kingdom fell, his life and those of his
sons and followers were saved.
He sailed to Middle-earth, founded the kingdoms
of Gondor and Arnor, and set up a legacy for
men on that continent that carried all the
way through to Aragorn at the time of The
Lord of the Rings.
It would be great to see this noble, beloved
king at the height of his power, or even resisting
Sauron's initial allure.
Celebrimbor is one of the most important figures
in the history of the Rings of Power themselves,
and while he didn't appear in Jackson's films,
his spirit is a major part of the Middle Earth:
Shadow of Mordor and Shadow of War games because
of his closeness to the Rings.
An Elven smith in the Second Age, Celebrimbor
was a skilled craftsman who was there when
Sauron came upon the Elves in his Annatar
guise and began teaching them how to make
rings.
Though he didn't exactly trust Annatar, he
did participate in the crafting of rings,
and personally made the three Elven Rings
of Power.
"Three were given to the Elves, immortal,
wisest, and fairest of all beings."
When Sauron revealed his treachery, Celebrimbor
worked to hide the Three Rings from the Dark
Lord so he could never wield their power.
He died under torture, after refusing to give
up the location of the Three to Sauron.
If you're going to touch on the story of how
the Rings of Power came to be, Celebrimbor
has a major role to play there.
If you're a fan of the Lord of the Rings books
and films, you're obviously already very familiar
with Sauron.
He's the main antagonist of J.R.R.
Tolkien's novel and Peter Jackson's film trilogy,
and proved so vital to the overall mythology
of Middle-earth that he was retroactively
inserted into The Hobbit as "The Necromancer"
Gandalf was investigating at the time.
It might seem like overkill to put the Dark
Lord in yet another story from this world,
but there's a good reason to bring Sauron
back.
Sauron is a character older than the physical
realm of Middle-earth itself, an ancient spirit
created as one of the Maiar alongside other
vastly powerful beings like Gandalf and Saruman.
That means you can find some version of him
in almost any part of the Tolkien timeline,
but in the Second Age he was particularly
devious.
To forge the Rings of Power in the first place,
Sauron took on a beautiful, more angelic form,
re-named himself Annatar, and called himself
the "Lord of Gifts" to trick the Elves into
making rings with him.
Seeing that version of Sauron, beautiful while
harboring a darker purpose, could lend a lot
of intrigue to the new series.
Círdan is one of the oldest and most important
Elves in all of Middle-earth lore, and that
granted him a brief cameo appearance in the
Lord of the Rings film trilogy, as a ring-bearer
in the prologue and at the Grey Havens in
the end.
That said, there's so much more to his story
that a TV series could explore.
Círdan was born before the First Age, and
by the time he finally left Middle-earth in
the Fourth Age, he'd been the oldest elf on
the continent for millennia.
In the Second Age, he established the Grey
Havens in the west of Middle-earth as a master
shipwright who loved to live near the water.
When Sauron attempted to deceive the Elves
into crafting the Rings of Power, Círdan
was one of the Elven leaders who resisted
the temptation, and when the Three Elven Rings
were hidden from Sauron, he was tasked with
bearing one of them.
He fought in the War of the Last Alliance
right up until its end, and in the books it
was he, not Elrond, who tried to convince
Isildur to destroy the One Ring.
"Cast it into the fire!
Destroy it!"
When we first meet Gandalf in Tolkien's The
Hobbit, he is presented as a wizard, but perhaps
a human one.
Over time, though, Tolkien laid out a complex
mythology for Gandalf and his wizard brethren,
and revealed them to be Maiar spirits sent
by the Valar 1,000 years into the Third Age
to aid against the rise of Sauron.
The Lord of the Rings features Gandalf the
Grey and Saruman the White in major roles,
while Radagast the Brown plays a slightly
smaller part in The Hobbit.
But there were two other wizards who didn't
get roles to play in The Lord of the Rings
or The Hobbit, and whose background and deeds
in Middle-earth remain rather vague.
In fact, it's possible that these Blue Wizards
- known as Alatar and Pallando - arrived before
the mission was handed down to the others,
sometime in the Second Age.
Hoping for their presence in the series might
be in vain, but there's so much untapped potential
in the idea of other wizards and what they
might have been up to that it seems like an
opportunity that shouldn't be passed up.
As Sauron's second in command during the War
of the Ring, the Witch-king of Angmar is a
major presence in the films, particularly
in The Return of the King, and we get to see
him riding into battle on behalf of his dark
master more than once.
"Do you not know death when you see it, old
man?
This is my hour!"
We even see his death scene courtesy of Eowyn.
What we don't ever get to see, apart from
a few hints, is exactly how the Witch-king
became the Witch-king.
We know from the poem that opens The Lord
of the Rings that Three Rings were given to
Elves, Seven to the Dwarves, and Nine to the
Men.
We also know from Tolkien's various writings
on the subject that only the leaders of Men
who bore the Nine were fully corrupted by
Sauron's influence.
They became the Nazgul, a.k.a. the Ringwraiths,
and the Witch-king was their leader.
What we know considerably less about is who
the Witch-king was before he was corrupted
by Sauron, and why exactly he was the one
among the Nine who rose to that particular
position of honor.
It's a mystery the series could shed some
light on in a really interesting way.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.